moldova's nights get darker and colder
with power saving all over the country
and now the energy crisis is compounded
by another power source being reduced or
cut it's from this hydroelectric plant
in the disputed territory of
transnistria Russian forces have been
here since separatists took control more
than 30 years ago this Soldier crosses
into moldovan territory asking for ID
documents we have an army on our
territory for more than 30 years
and we have a frozen conflict
where the Russians are also part of it
and when you see that the Rockets
Russian missiles are flying
above our territory and part of them are
failing falling on our villages
and of course
you are feeling threatened in this
situation
and there are frequent reminders of
Russian influence here even though the
government says these pro-russian
demonstrations are orchestrated by an
exiled oligarch
most people support the government in
looking to the west but Moldova isn't in
NATO or the European Union and its
collapsed economy is getting even weaker
the people of Moldova are finding it
harder than ever to get by inflation
right now stands at 30 percent no
surprise then that the population of two
and a half million is shrinking at one
of the fastest rates in the world as
more and more young people move overseas
to find work
anishwara pasika's plight shows what so
many moldovan families are up against
her husband has cut two trees down to
provide enough warmth for one room the
gas heating is Switched Off they can't
afford it now anishwara is alone with
her children her husband had to fly to
Germany a few days ago to find work
honestly I never thought life would
bring us to the point where we have to
live apart our house feels so sad now
will have to live with insecurity unless
she and her family leave their Homeland
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera kishinao
Moldova